there we go all right thank you very
much for that kind introduction
I know I don't have ten minutes so I'm
gonna make this really fast the name my
talk somehow maybe probably my fault
didn't make it into the schedule in time
and I appreciate anyone showing everyone
showing up anyway but I actually
struggle this a bit because I do a
number of webinars kind of as a CTO and
you know like there's a lot of things I
do talking to customers and whatnot but
it's been a while since I've done a
community talk and so you know coming
back from the hinterlands of customers
and money and all that stuff thinking
about what are the what are the things
what is the message that if I have a
chance to to speak to fellow Python
Easter's what is the message that I want
to send what are things I've learned and
and what not especially because this
caught this particular instance so this
particular conference actually marks the
20th according to Leah's xx PI data
conference right so that's really
amazing and as Brian said it's it comes
together because of the hard work of
volunteers all the all the speakers that
work very hard on their talks and the
content all tutorial presenters
everybody works together and and it's
just been amazing that in four years we
have we have put together 20 conferences
and hundreds and hundreds of talks only
230 or so our thumbnail here but but
there are lots and lots and there be
more if we could find a few of the ones
that we lost right if the stream said
yeah so so in a sense I wanted to sort
of always look back to see where have we
you know how how far have we come where
did we come from and really you know
what's changed in the four years since
we started this as a little tiny
workshop you know at the Google campus
and a lot actually has changed I would
say that one of the biggest things is
that now versus so four years ago 24
2012 there's a lot fewer of this are
versus Python stuff right and I think
that I would like to think that it's
because Python showed up and just
dominate it so hard there's no point
arguing anymore
but because if it really sucked there'd
be a lot more of it and then it would
fade away in our woodwind right but but
actually I think what ends up happening
is as people started using both of these
things more and more for real work they
stopped arguing about stuff and just
kept using the tools and making the
tools better and it sort of ceased to be
an issue for most people but of course
now we also get the scala versus python
thing so we won't you know not getting
that until later but actually one of the
things that definitely I think has
changed especially talking to customers
and being out in kind of big data
industry conferences and things like
that is that that it's clear that Python
and are it's clear to me and I think is
clear to the most people that Python and
R are here to stay right so many people
who are teaching data science like
galvanize and so many others the
curricula are based on Python and are I
mean it's like what else you're going to
do right so that's a really really
powerful statement I think about just
you know these are here to stay this
this is basically what's here and so
kind of tied to that pythons become sort
of normal in the space and for those of
you who are somewhat maybe new to this
ecosystem or to the community that
wasn't always the case in 2012 there was
there was a lot of and four years after
that even though they were sort of like
well but python is just the scripting
language right like it's the slow
scripting language there's a gill that
makes it really bad and so why are you
using that thing it's you know maybe
maybe we'll use it now six months later
we'll replace it with something more
real and that kind of conversation has
also gone away that so many people have
looked around and the peer validation
the fact there's so many companies just
doing real stuff with Python it's become
normal in this space and in fact you
know deep learning I would say that
Python is like the dominant language in
deep learning it's a very exciting new
area of data science and machine
learning and automate statistics and all
of the the papers being out all of them
but many of the papers been published
the new algorithm we discussed knew new
libraries they all have Python embedded
in them or implemented a Python and
additionally one thing that here in the
PI data community as we're talking about
pythons applicability for data science
we might you know compartmentalize just
that thinking but a thing that it's
worth bringing up is that in the
scientific Python and the HPC and
engineering simulation side of things
pythons
dominants there continues the momentum
continues and accelerating excuse me too
much coffee so the so that the the the
general idea here is that across the
board in the last four years we've seen
an accelerating adoption of python in
the super exciting and again is do the
hard work of a lot of volunteers in the
community the Python community is not
that commercial and so there's you know
everyone that's pushing that forward
they're pushing it out of a somewhat
self-preservation but also out of a love
for the tools and technology I think and
one of the things that also maybe is
somewhat of a controversial statement
but I don't shy away from those but in
the I would say that in the last four
years what we've seen is really when we
started continuum you know clearly
Hadoop was at the peak of his ascendancy
I would say and now sort of the first
age of Hadoop is drawing to a close and
that it means going away to be clear
it's here and it's still growing but the
first wave of that you know the Gartner
hype cycle we press to that wave and
that happened last four years and that's
changed the conversation for us as
Python data scientists as well so the
other thing to note of course is that
whenever is the first stage there's a
second one right and I would say the
second age is not yet here and and and
what I mean by that is that when I think
we'll see kind of in some later slides
the second age of not just Hadoop but of
kind of the data all this data
revolution type stuff that I think will
be here when we see people thinking
about the bandwidth between storage and
compute as being the first class
concerned as opposed to merely capacity
or CPU speed and that's I think I'm take
probably another two to three years for
it to really hit mainstream but the
inevitability of that happening it
should be clear to most people that were
working in this space now so that's
things that have changed in the last
four years I think it's actually more
interesting to talk about what hasn't
changed and one of the things that
hasn't changed is that data is
everywhere and there's just more of it
it's Messier and that just continues
there's not changed at all we could put
it all in Hadoop it still is messy right
so it doesn't really solve the problem
so the other thing though around data
being everywhere growing is that
actually the data is not even the
hardest part of the problem and the
thing that we've seen are the last four
years that
you know I think makes this more
interesting is the fact that everything
around the data is also changing at the
same time so not only are we debating
sequel vs. no sequel not only are we
debating like you know different kinds
of technologies for the data warehouse
and architectures but all of the stuff
around data is also changing and that's
the compute the the hardware the you
know the analytical routines and
algorithms everything around data is
changing and I'm gonna go through this
load more quickly but but the idea here
is that for the last 25 or 30 years
we've really existed in somewhat of a
monoculture at the lowest levels of
infrastructure technology the x86
instruction set and Intel's chips being
dominant has been the way of the world
for 30 years there's other stuff to
that's that's kind of around but but for
the most part in business computing x86
was it and then if you're talking
Abhisek imputing as well then then
Windows was the dominant platform and
then only the last you know 10 12 years
has Linux really ascended into a
mainstream position on the server side
and again there's other stuff there but
for the most part we've lived in a
period relative monoculture relative to
be you know before the the previous 30
years there was just everyone was
cobbling hardware and software stuff
together and trying to make custom
languages and custom network stacks to
do all sorts of weird stuff so basically
your most of your dabs in the last 30
years that they basically were gonna
write some code in Java or.net deploy on
a pretty standard back-end they didn't
have to think about weird things like
Numa didn't have to worry about cache
coherency those are things that like
maybe people doing exotic cluster
computing would worry about but your
mainstream person only had to worry
about the top part the stack what we're
seeing now of course is that the whole
bottom part of the stack is blowing up
and so for instance we have GPUs many
people here in this room I'm sure are
playing with or experimenting with deep
learning and that right there is five
teraflops on a chip right that's I think
Pascal chip we have Amazon AWS and other
cloud vendors actively encouraging us to
stop thinking about computers as a box
with a CPU a CPU fan on hard drive but
rather to think about actually doing a
software-defined cloud scale cloud first
architecture for our information system
right
and then of course because we're blowing
up the lower end of the stack that also
means we have to muscle around with what
enough what an operating system is or is
not or gets wrapped another operating
system whatever and if you think about
all this disruption kind of all this
stuff happening you know Hadoop as I've
mentioned Hadoop is actually just one
instance of this disruption happening in
a particular niche which is the data
warehousing niche and so this same thing
is happening on every single other
aspect of business data processing and
and so you know instead of thinking
about all of these different like this
traditional stack we now have to think
about well we're encouraged to think
about a much more deconstructed set of
technological legos and and the reason
the way this matters so much for
analytics is that actually all the stuff
we tend to use a run into is really old
like even numpy is quite old at this
point and all of these things were built
on top of that traditional like single
node kind of kind of paradigm and and so
in terms of you know what hasn't changed
what hasn't changed is that the stuff is
really old
you know it's maybe four years older now
but it's still really old and what
hasn't changed is that all of you know
all of this stuff continues apace right
but but again more stuff is coming down
the pike okay so then you know who okay
and who's not a continuum know what this
is picture of well okay some kind of
semiconductor device right so this is
basically and actually that's the best I
could say because it basically looks
like memory all right it doesn't look
like hell at quality of CPU but actually
it's a thing called 3d xpoint and it is
not like memory because it's persistent
so it's persistent storage okay so it's
kind of like an SSD but it's a thousand
times faster than SSD so it's basically
like memory but it's not like memory
because it's 10 times more dense than
memory so your 1 terabyte or 2 terabyte
of RAM server that you have under your
desk hopefully that thing is going to be
able to go 10x in terms of density and
you never have like it you never have to
free your memory because it's just like
you know a malloc is a right and so it's
persistent memory class storage and this
is coming down the pike so the hard
a kind of level disruption that's
happening to how we think about
operating systems and compute and all
that stuff all that stuff is only going
to accelerate harder right oh by the way
this is they're going to make this
available I think for GA in 2017 so
you'll be able to plug it into a dim
socket you'll be able to plug it into an
nvme class like SSD storage I mean you
can do a lot of things with it but this
is an Intel and micron joint joint
technology but the basic idea here is
for those of you who are kind of not
maybe like software developer developers
what this kind of thing means is that
you never have to quit an application so
your applications they say they they
come up and they kind of hang around
they create stuff in memory and it just
sits there and so that kind of three
think I mean that's never been the case
as far as long as I've been programming
AI programming for a while now right so
this idea that you don't need a Save
button
all applications always running for all
time fundamentally changes how we think
about processing how we think about data
architectures and infrastructure all of
those things change right and so I guess
to kind of wrap all this up what hasn't
changed is that we are still just at the
beginning of the data revolution we're
just at the beginning of it even four
years later because that wave is so big
we're still at the very early age stages
of that and and that the technology
innovation though is accelerating it's
definitely getting faster and faster
people who maybe four or five years ago
thought like oh if I just get the Hadoop
and I go on the cloud I'm good I'm
really good for a while but actually
know it's going to get worse and worse
and worse
so every aspect of how we ingest and how
we store and how we manage and process
data is going to change from here on out
so actually probably two or three years
from now you'll look back and maybe more
people start realizing you know the 80s
90s early 2000s that little unique
period of monoculture it was an anomaly
actually and that won't have so much
that we could be processing on data and
we have so much data to process and so
many different Legos to put together we
actually have to kind of like think
again about how we're gonna put the
stuff together and be very thoughtful
our engineering around information
systems but with all of that kind of
technology let's say churn right we
might ask well how much of this is
actually innovation how much of this is
just churn because it's clear
there's new open source project new
hacker news every day like data
technology is like extremely noisy and
confusing especially so if you're not a
technologist per se but you are a buyer
right if you're a customer if you're a
manager you know in some business you
try to figure out what what databases
are this week you know it's named after
some goofy sci-fi character or is it
named something whatever like I don't
know but I guess so I guess they use the
Twitter so it maybe it's good so that
kind of thinking right is very it's very
confusing people it doesn't even feel
good and we laugh about it but it's not
it's not great to have to be in that
situation and so the the fundamental
truth is that the innovation and the
disruption is real and if you if it
forces you to think about your
fundamental problems that's good right
so you're like wait what am i doing you
why am i doing that why are we doing
this thing over here like and you should
kind of drill down to the bedrock of
what is my actual problem that's great
so keep doing that and you'll at least
track to something relevant to your
actual problem the opposite of that are
band-aids on band-aids on band-aids and
generally the way that works is a vendor
comes in and says hey you know if you do
this you don't have to worry about this
anymore right great sale great sale when
the bedrock is not like shifting around
on earthquake going on you can just do
that you just keep putting more more
stuff under the rug nowadays though what
you end up doing is buying into stuff
that then next year changes and then
next year will change again and so
you're just kind of on this cycle and so
this this this general kind of dichotomy
because I get some this feedback
sometimes and talking to people about
this concept is like oh there's so much
churn now just like I wish I could just
call somebody I'll call my rep up at IBM
and make it all go away or something
right and the problem is the rep can't
make go away either because they're in
the middle of it right everyone is
trying to figure this out so it has to
be you have to insource that knowledge
you have to actually think about what is
the problem I'm trying to solve and and
and not just can I solve it with this
new thing I read about a hacker news but
actually fundamentally what is the
problem I'm trying to solve at the data
level at the computational level so
think about data movement thinking about
bandwidth thinking about all of those
different things and if you think about
that then you start getting scanning
skills as individuals that are going to
be relevant across many different
business as many different sectors
because everyone's going to have that
basically fundamentally the same kinds
of afflictions as we go
this new era of big data so one of the
things that encourage then is that in
the short term you should be pragmatic
in the long term you have to be
strategic you might say that's kind of a
logical because strategy is long-term
but fundamentally that the the insight
here is that people change and learn
slower than machines do so if you're
going to invest in people to make sure
those are long-term investments if
you're going to invest in people make
sure those are long-term investments
make sure their learning technologies
that are going to be relevant for the
long term make sure they're learning
about problems and approaches that are
relevant in the long term the
infrastructure and the code the things
you build out today are going to change
in two years almost certainly they're
gonna change in massive ways in two
years so now is a great time to think
about what what parts of my problem are
deep what are fundamental how do I hire
the right people and give them the right
skills to over the long term be able to
solve this problem not merely hey I need
ten Python data scientists to our guys
and five scholar programmers to deploy
the start the spark thing and the next
year maybe I don't know what my move is
Cassandra spark and Cassandra but yeah
it's ready right now for the next six
months and so like that's not the right
mindset but people do literally think
like that we can laugh about it all we
want to but the big big one management
here is to think about technology
short-term pragmatic kind of things but
people people who know how to architect
that technology those are long-term sort
of investments long-term sort of folks
and so I've been talking a lot here even
those the kind of community talk I've
been talking a lot about business
adoption of Python is be and that's
because that's kind of my lived
experience for last while now so I've
done a talk like this before about
Python meeting the Emprise it was a
really great line you talk but but I
want to do this again kind of more
formally and this is the 2016 edition
essentially and the basically the the
big the big thing here the big concept
about Python in the enterprise is that
people always fundamentally
misunderstand Python like I've very
seldom walk in places where they really
get it and the reason is because it's
very unique there are there's I would
say no other language that's like Python
in the ability to actually spend
multiple different tribes of usage as
completely as Python does so the and the
really hard thing for data science is
that if you put a data side
just in front of a computer or Python
shell or Python editor and you put us
Python software developer in front of a
computer with the Python shell and a
Python editor open to the manager it
looks like they're both coding right but
they're actually both in we're laughing
here because we know they're doing very
very different things right and so the
Python developer the web developer or
whatever like they are getting paid to
make code that's what they do the data
scientist is trying to write as little
code as they absolutely have to to get
to some analysis some analytical insight
you know that's what they're getting
paid for is not to generate a whole pile
of code they might have to as a as a
faster means to getting to the insights
but that's ultimately the big difference
here and businesses are not actually
equipped to think in this way that they
tend to think about and this this idea
of pigeonholing
they tend to think about if you're
typing code into a file and you're
saving that file and checking it in your
developer and the developers in the IT
organization and here's what we use an
ID we use Java and or or if you said
well no actually we're doing predictive
modeling and there's a little insights
and there's a logistic regression oh
great you're an analyst well here's your
Excel and here's your SAS right so this
kind of bifurcation is how businesses
have thought about this for a very long
time and they can build these silos on
this foundation that's not moved in 30
years but is now finally starting to
fracture in a fundamental way and you
see this a lot when people deploy Hadoop
and they completely rethink if schema on
read their entire data architecture data
warehouse changes and now they have no
idea what to call different people you
know your Scala SPARC guys are the data
scientists are they data engineers the
Python people coming in with some
scripts to mind some stuff do some ETL
are they a data engineer are they a data
scientist right like if that ETL code in
the middle of it calls Syfy dot you know
something it's not really ETL anymore
it's some other [ __ ] right observe some
other stuff right and so the idea is
that the traditional ways of
pigeonholing these folks is falling
apart as we're changing out the software
and the hardware infrastructures and as
we bring in people like yourselves who
are equipped with skills to be
cross-cutting right so you go in there
and you're just some kind of ninja and
it's like well would you what do you
want to eat archery ninja or a sword and
I don't know but I'm just a ninja right
so this this idea but you laugh but it's
actually a problem for people because if
you go try to get a job at the one these
places they're gonna they're gonna say
do you want a sword or do you want you
know a bow and you might want both it's
like well we don't have that right so so
it's really and this this kind of it
shows up in the broader communications
and the broader kind of discussions
around this stuff too because I just ran
into this particularly exceptionally
unknowing blog post not too long ago and
this this guy is really interesting I
mean I don't you know his lived
experiences his lived experience and I
will not denigrate that but the the the
concepts that are being pushed here I
think really fundamentally speak to the
kinds of problems that arise in
businesses around this so basically
although she has read a little bit
basically when I guess PhD mathematics
stats whatever trying to find a data
science job going for interviews and
makes the claim that you want to called
up 50 something companies at 24
interviews and with a few exceptions
Python was clearly frowned upon for a
data science job and no one ever told me
I couldn't use Python but his you know I
didn't put here in the quote but you
know one situation he was asked a
question that required you know ideally
the use of a heap but he was not built
in and so he wanted to use it Q or
something but that wasn't installed in
the interview environment and so was
awkward now if they're using anaconda
and given him Conda and you know network
connection to be done but the point is
that but the point is that this idea is
what I see in this and this other thing
that's really cool interesting well I'll
get that in a second but the idea here
is that if you go an interview for a
data science job if that data science
job is being put out there by the IT
department it's made a different kind of
data science job than if it's put out by
some business analysts or line of
business right and so the other but the
other piece of this that's interesting
was he said you know I so I decided
learn you know I learned some Scala and
he was how you used that in the in the
interview process and I just actually
love this the interviewers actually
encouraged me to use Scala even when
they were not familiar with the language
they would trust the repple to auto my
code and and they would I guess use the
time to dress more gentle points okay
but then they would follow me on Twitter
so this
is this but this is a real phenomenon
right and and there's nothing wrong with
with Scala as a language there's nothing
wrong with with clearly SPARC Scala as
the technology stack it's just this
general I this general confusion and in
Hayes as businesses try to move into
modern data science I guess and and what
they suffer and this is this little
following about Twitter and oh I don't
even know this language you're using but
I read about it at hacker news is really
cool and so you must be more awesome
than me that is what I call the open
source head fake and it's a real it's a
real thing now and there's billions of
dollars attached to this believe it or
not like it's a real thing and what I
mean is that businesses when I go to
businesses and all right hear from
businesses they want open source they're
interested open source
there's basically two maybe three
reasons they're interested in open
source one of them is because they're
tired of lock-in vendor lock-in
proprietary stacks prior technology
technology and also it's harder for them
to harness innovation so the brighter
more clue focuses have moved onto using
open source and they recognize that
they're able to tap into newer things
faster rather than having some vendor
stodgy old vendor kind of gating them
and the other piece is that they
recognize there's a serious how long
we're going on especially in the data
side of things and so if they're using
open source stuff they have a better
time recruiting so those are real those
are the three primary concerns I've
heard basically but what what ends up
kind of getting lost the noise in this
conversation is that people don't I
don't know why but they sort of not
realize that open source is not just
about slapping a license on a pile of
source code like just because someone
can give you a source code table you've
got nothing it's like free puppy or free
free truck full of puppies right all the
Big Joe a puppy in a jar puppy in a jar
no that's not valuable right actually
what's valuable about great open source
is that there's a community of people
that either
have come along to support it or that
created it usually it's you know a few
key people solving their own problem
that also can code that create that
first little that they kind of the
inception of the of the project and then
it spreads and it gets adopted by a
community of people it takes a village
essentially raise real open source and
that is sometimes law that means I think
lost with many people in the community
itself so not our community but overall
in software dilemma community
and in other times businesses actually
don't get it they sort of can't tell
some open source with some other open
source it's kind of like if you go to
the grocery store and you're buying
organic everyone knows they want organic
but you know like if the if it's spelled
wrong if it's like you know like printed
with well anyway the point is there's
real organic and there's the organic
that sort of is like and you know and so
here I think an open source we see a
bunch of that people are real actually
people are using the prevalence of
social media and online communications
to actually turn open-source into did
they proxy a bunch of other stuff on it
becomes a self emotion tool it becomes
gamified it's you know all these other
things and and it's not well it's
whatever it is people use the internet
however they want to but for businesses
trying to consume better innovation and
better more innovative software and for
people like us who are users of that
software it matters a great deal that we
have good stuff coming in right so one
of the things that's really important
about this I realized is and maybe an
obvious point to many of you but but but
something that I've finally been able to
put words to you in the last year or so
is a corollary of Conway's law so just
for those who are not familiar Conway's
law it was a guy came out with in like
1960s 68 some like that and it said that
any piece of software reflects the
communications structure of the
organization that produced it
if you hire three subcontractors to
build a piece of software you can get
three components in that software right
and so there's a corollary of this that
I've discovered or whatever been a
loophole words on to which is idea that
business data architecture ultimately
evolves to reflect the budget structure
of the IT people that maintain it it is
not optimized for strategic and and
long-term operational needs it's not
optimized for ensuring future agility it
is certainly not optimized for
generating insight it is optimized so
that some IT guy is able to say here's
how much I spent on licenses for this
part of the database that extension this
little Excel add-on and this other thing
over here and by IT I mean also the
software groups that usually fall under
the IT budget of people that built
internal data systems and internal
business applications and this concept
that basically businesses have optimized
to buy technology existing or legacy
technology in a certain way it means
that they have a hard time consuming new
innovation even when it's free even when
the licensing cost is zero they don't
actually know how
operationalize that how to build
accountability structures internally and
so the admonition I give to them is look
don't start the unicorns you know
everyone says data scientists you guys
are here in San Francisco statisticians
attempt Cisco's data scientists so if
you want to call if you wanna get those
unicorns once you get them in the door
don't starve them right the way that
businesses tend to by actually pushes
power away from data science
capabilities because data science is
incredibly cross-cutting thing it's very
exploratory it's very experimental it is
science right you're you have hypotheses
you're gathering new information you're
integrating things and you're trying to
come up with more it's more powerful
explanations and so information systems
have traditionally essentially ossified
now into just software hardware you know
I got data senator babies moving to
cloud I get these different pieces of
software I stitch them together and for
data processing that's fine like that's
okay you know what data is coming in you
know what you want out of it you can
make reports you're all good but if you
want human-in-the-loop systems where
you're actively coming up with new ideas
and you're actively drilling into new
areas and you're trying to all this
crazy stuff you're producing you know
you're doing inference you're producing
inside knowledge that is not a
traditional just like straight through
business data processing problem and and
so the architecture of how you even do
that is is as a new discipline for
businesses and so I mean the way that
it's it's interesting once I came to
this understanding I was like oh well
that's why they're not getting it
because they think they can take the
Unicorn stick it over here and treat
like a cat but it's not really a cat you
know so so this but so it but it's a bit
of Education to convince businesses to
actually go and change how their budget
structures are is very very difficult
and it takes time but many of them are
stern to come around now which is great
and that brings me to my talk which is
python for Python East is now actually
so so the end of the day though I'm
often you know led into sort of these
conversations around about advocacy of
like why to use Python why you know
sometimes there's data scientists there
who are like of course we're using
Python don't bother about that asking
this other stuff right but um but I
think it's important for all of us to be
able to articulate well the core value
proposition in Python I think that for
me the way I've always thought about it
is that it's about empowerment that it
is not just technology for technology's
sake it is not just another churn of the
technology wheel it's actually this idea
that we can empower
smart individuals who wonder
and some domain problem to go and access
all the data and access all the compute
that they need to go answer those
questions and come up with better
questions more importantly and this is
actually it's worth noting this is
actually very unique in the history of
technology that technology usually when
it gets powerful and valuable it quickly
specializes in to a specialist race car
a specialist airplane a specialist thing
and then you kind of have this hyper
specialization evolution of people who
are able to drive those race cars and
airplanes and everything but python is
actually extremely generic tooling and
so that that's that's a challenge for
businesses because now if every single
data analyst who you know they might
they might not be happy about the fact
that that so many of the insights come
out of Excel but at least they can
manage a floor full of Excel analysts
but if you give that floor full Excel
analysts the unlimited power of the
entire Python stack or R or spark or
whatever and you give them access to all
this data they should have access to and
they understand the business problems
think about what they could do its
enormous ly disruptive and businesses
don't necessarily operate that way so
it's almost like you know again the free
puppy thing you get a unicorn now we're
gonna do with a unicorn your kitchen
right so this is the problem that
actually operationalizing the human
change that that means is has been a
process for them but however I think
it's extremely important for us as
Python Python users as Python you know
committed folks that we are able to
recognize that challenge and articulate
why it's important to take that take
that step and may and you know overcome
that hurdle so to wrap this all up
you know pie data is only four years
young we're gonna be around for much
much much longer a lot of great things
to do still and if you hear whether
you're PI committed or PI curious you're
all part of it you're all part of that
community alright and so one of these
that I think to point out is that
actually the the fact that we have so
many people who are new how many were
here how many people here is this
through your first PI data event thank
you so much for coming out on a weekend
on this just like terrible weather in
San Francisco and you know
hiding away in the basement but but
actually it's really important that I
think the Python community as a language
big tent community it has it stresses
openness stresses being welcoming and
diverse and its really stresses the
education and the onboarding of new
people into the community in PI data is
no different in that in fact I would
argue that because of the unique
position of what Python is that it's
both a user language as well as a
software developer language if we don't
constantly get a stream of new users
coming in telling us I don't know how to
use this or I don't see why this is put
together this way if we don't get that
then we actually are going to suffer the
problems of ossification we will be
vulnerable to the problem of being an
echo chamber where we're making cool
things for ourselves and then everyone
else is like what's that weird stuff
right so the new experiences and the new
perspectives the the kind of newbie
questions of like Oh forgive me for
being a newbie but why does this do this
those questions are features like we up
that perspective is really important for
us as a community and I think every
single I mean look at the list here all
of different projects in the in the
Python and the scientific Python the PI
data communities all those significant
projects that have taken taken on a
certain momentum they all really
appreciate that kind of input and that
input is what's been what's made them
powerful I think and really relevant and
so two years ago I was at PI data we had
probably prior to the cell valley down
in Facebook and I had this slide where I
said actually the most important the
single most important thing is
fundamentally still community right and
that absolutely has not changed the this
idea that it is a community of users a
community of makers a community of
actually nowadays vendors and buyers and
recruiters and employers and everybody
it is a vibrant vibrant community of
people and that's actually really really
critical and that ensures our relevance
even as technology's changing underneath
us even though to make new things and
adapt things to old things and all this
other stuff as long as we actually take
care of the people aspects then the
technology will sort itself out so I
would encourage all of you those who
have been here in the ecosystem and the
community for a long time to keep doing
what you're doing
all those who have volunteered their
time to organize events like this those
who are prepared to who
who have prepared stalks thank you all
of you for what you do and I encourage
you to do more of it and all the people
who are new to this stuff I encourage
you to participate be active you know
make your voice heard contribute in
whatever way you can we actually feel
that the community part of Python pi
data
Sify that community is the single most
important feature many people have said
about python that they came for the
language they stayed for the community
and I think pi data it should be no
different so thank you very much
do you have any time for talk for
questions or a couple minutes any
questions yes
so for businesses to understand Python
the ones that have gotten it the most
that I've interacted with are ones where
they recognize that they what they
generally do is they recognize the data
science capabilities are not only
radically above and beyond and what
their current infrastructure is but that
their organization can absorb it so
they've actually recognized it and the
executive level they bring in someone
who is a head of analytics or chief
analytics officer that goes and creates
maybe maybe tie to the CTO office or
something like that and they create a
center of excellence or some kind of
like cross-functional like Tiger team of
people and those people go and they
actually kind of do that internal
transformation so for big businesses
that's what I've seen but the other
thing is that there's a tremendous
amount of influence wielded by those
participating in social media so many
people in corporate America are
firewalled off and cannot go and
participate in the discussions but you
know if you tweeted all about data
science your tweets hurting it read by
dozens and dozens of people that are
actually influencing their decision
makers in the space it's kind of a weird
thing because in traditional enterprise
software vendor whatever kind of things
people pay a lot for that influence
right I mean we know we pay to show up
at Gardner people pay to you know being
all these are the kinds of things that
influencing technology decisions is a
really big business but we're seeing
more more businesses actually being
transformed by input from kind of social
validation kind of peer validation by
practitioners as opposed to simply like
what vendor ARAG did I read that said
this and I'm a CIO so I should buy this
like that's that's that's happening it's
a natural organic process great question
any other questions yes
mm-hmm
yes so how so the question is I just
recently and I'm trying to convince them
and show them how using scripts and
using kind of more programmatic approach
to analysis it's more powerful and
better than Excel and well don't laugh
don't laugh
a lot of the world runs in Excel so so
that is a real question right because
it's easy for us to get into this very
like oh holy earth like not higher than
that sort of thing where because I can
write a script to do what you do in ten
minutes
you know and I can like that it's very
easy to kind of get in this mentality
but actually I would say the best way to
do it like if I were in that position I
would find the people who are most
respected in that tribe of Excel people
find those people find what's killing
their day like I used to know this lady
who worked in an investment bank who had
a four year old HP laptop that would get
locked up for two hours every day
because she was doing a gigantic vlookup
to difference two million row
spreadsheets and it was an N squared
process rights for each row vlookup the
other table for the next item vlookup
the whole day and I was like so
literally this is a set intersection of
two I mean this is built into PI it you
don't even need to like this scala guy
you didn't even import anything to do a
set intersection right and so the
ability to write a small script and
solve her two hour a day of no computer
problem really helped right so those are
the sorts of things I would say it's
extremely tactical it's winning hearts
and minds and as opposed to persuading
kind of just help right because if you
are so incredibly badass with your
Python you should make their days much
better right so do it
right and that was it that's that's
where the proof is no I'm not no no but
you know I'm saying like I'm the proof
is in the pudding there so if you I mean
learn learns of the Excel plug-in type
things show them how much better the
graphics can be if they use you know
Jupiter notebooks they use things like
okay you can do some really cool stuff
that they just can't do in in Excel and
so so while you may be proceeding
strategically from perspective of long
term this is a great value to our
company in the short term the hearts and
minds thing is about winning that tribe
of people over and a lot of times it's
just about curing their daily pains you
know the special relative Excel users
doing it anymore time we're out okay
whatever thank you everyone so much